All right, so now we've talked about two
different algorithms, TD(0) and TD(1).
And what we'd like to do next is show
that, in fact, there is a larger
algorithm that actually includes
both of those as special cases.
And so
we're going to write that as TD(lambda),
and it's going to have the property
that when lambda is set to 0,
we get TD(0), and
when lambda is set to 1, we get TD(1).
But we also get update rules for all
sorts of in-between values of lambda.
>> I don't know, that sounds
kind of like witchcraft to me.
>> [LAUGH] No, no, no it's just
algorithm design, it's all good.
>> Hm, all right,
well I'll believe it when I see it.
>> In particular, what's going to let us
do that is the fact that both TD(0) and
TD(1), the way that we were writing
them, have updates that are based on
differences between temporally
successive predictions.
Temporal differences,
that's the TD part.
And so
we can actually unite them into one and,
I don't need to say that again,
because I've already said it.
>> All right.
>> So
I copied the algorithm back down here.
And do you know which
algorithm [LAUGH] this is?
And the hope is that it's a little
bit challenging because, in fact,
if it's TD(0) or it's TD(1), they
actually look an awful lot the same.
They have a lot of stuff in common.
The update rule itself looks almost
identical, but they are different.
So which one is this?
>> I'm trying to remember.
And let's see, well, let's see.
There's a 0 in one line and
a 1 in another line so
that's not going to help me.
I was hoping I could
the number pf 1s and 0s.
>> [LAUGH] Actually,
there's a bunch of 1, right.
There's a (St-1), and there's another 1,
and here's another 1, and
here's another 1, and another 1.
>> Yeah, but
most of those are -1s, not +1s.
I mean,
you didn't ask me if it was TD(-1).
>> So maybe this is TD(-1).
>> Oh, that probably suggests that the
way I was going about this was wrong.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I think it's TD(1).
>> All right, and
you have any particular reason for that?
>> Because I recall TD(1)
had a bunch of e's in it.
>> Yes,
it is easy to tell the difference.
So e here, the eligibility, is something
that doesn't show up in the TD(0) rule
the way that we wrote it, but
it does show up in TD(1).
This sort of idea that what we're
going to do is we're going to update
the values for all states, all s.
And the amount that we
do this same update
varies depending on the current
eligibility of that state in question.
>> Okay, that seems reasonable.
I feel better now.
>> All right, and so to highlight
the similarities and differences between
TD(1) and TD(0), I took the TD(1)
algorithm that we just had and
shrunk it and moved it over to the left.
And then made another copy of it,
put it on the right, and
made the minimum changes necessary to
turn TD(1), what was TD(1), into TD(0).
And so mainly all that it involved was,
any time the eligibility was mentioned,
I kind of get rid of it.
So I got rid of it from there,
I got rid of it from there.
And I don't multiply it here
against the temporal update, and
I don't have to update it here.
And the only other difference, other
than just getting rid of all references
to the eligibility trace, is where as in
TD(1) we do this update over all states,
in TD(0) we just update the state
that we left most recently.
So I changed that loop.
[LAUGH] Instead of making it a loop,
it actually is just says for all s=st-1.
In other words, we are just going
to do this update for S=St-1.
All right, so now we are ready
to describe the TD(lambda) rule.
What I have done now,
is I got rid of those words and
I took the TD(1) rule and
copied it up here.
So this is currently TD(1).
And what we now need to do to it is
make changes to it, small as we can,
so that it turns it into T (0)
when lambda is equal to 0.
So we need to introduce a lambda.
So here's what I'm going to do,
just to kind of cut to the chase.
I'm going to take this gamma
decay of the eligibility.
And I'm going to change
it to a lambda gamma
decay of the eligibility trace, right?
So all I've done here is, it's exactly
TD(lambda), except I just threw in
an extra lambda here as a multiplier
in the update of the eligibility role.
And boom, we're done.
>> Okay, so wait, okay, right.
So I was raised to never put two
Greek letters next to one another.
But this does, do I buy this?
Okay so if lambda is 1 then,
well, nothing's changed,
it's exactly the same
algorithm as before.
>> Right, great, because [LAUGH]
if lambda's equal to 1 and
we're just multiplying this lambda
in there, then nothing's changed.
So, boom, it really is, and
it was TD(1) and it is TD(1).
>> Right, so let's see,
what happens is lambda is 0?
Well, for the thing we just looked at,
that means it's 0.
So you just set yes,
the eligibility trace equal to 0.
>> Right.
>> But,
you started out with it being equal
to 0 too so let's go back to the top.
So let's see, for all S if S is 0,
which is where we started out at
the start of the episode, that's nice.
Then we update e(S sub t
-1) to be e sub s(t+1).
So now e sub s(t) = 1.
>> Right, good, okay, so the eligibility
of the state that we just left gets
bumped up to one, that's right.
>> And everything else is 0.
>> Now we loop over all states.
>> Right, and we update V sub
t(s) to be this thing times,
well, it'll be 0 for
everything except for S(t-1).
>> Good.
>> And then we will take the eligibility
for that state and set it equal to 0.
>> Right so, iin particular on this
update, the eligibility is 0 for
all the S's not equal to S(t-1),
so nothing gets changed there.
And for the one where it is equal
to S(t-1), its eligibility is 1.
So we just do it,
we just update based on that,
which is exactly what we have for
the TD(0) rule.
And then right, as you say, we zero out
the eligibility and start it all again.
So it's almost like, it just briefly
remembers where it needs to update and
then it loses that memory right away,
goes right back into forgetful mode.
>> Although that won't matter
anyway because you're doing it
for every S once.
And then you'll pop back up and
do the episode again, and
you start all over again.
It's like an invariant, and so.
>> Oh, but that's only at the end of the
episode, so we really only pop back to,
right, when we're doing these updates,
this is after
each little t transition, so
>> This part we're actually going to
execute over, and over, and over again,
until the end of the episode.
So we don't zero out the eligibility
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> In fact, using lambda equal to zero
here, it has the same effect as it,
so we don't really need to do that.
>> Exactly.
Okay, so then the right thing happens.
>> Yeah, so when lambda's equal to zero,
boom we get TD(0), and
when lambda's equal to one,
boom we get TD(1).
And so, I guess what makes this
interesting is not just that we
can cleverly shoehorn
two algorithms into one,
but that it allows us to actually use
values of lambda that are in-between
which gives us kind of
elements of both of these.
It has TD0ish things to it and
TD1ish things to it, and
what we're going to look at next
is how to think about this rule.
This generalized TD lambda rule, so
that it kind of makes some sense so
that it kind of grounds it into
quantities that we can understand.
>> I look forward to that.